- Dru mate, just slow down.
- Yeah, tell us
exactly what happened.
- I don't know exactly.
It was about 02:00
a.m. last night
(dance music)
♪ The bodies swinging
in like a wrecking ball
♪ People getting naked
for no reason at all
♪ Girls puking up and
tongues down throats
♪ Uncle Ami's telling
all his racist jokes
♪ After the after after party
(rock music)
♪ Woke up in a pool of red
♪ Crimson knife lying by the bed
♪ Splatter marks
on the kitchen door
♪ What went wrong?
♪ Stale smell hanging in the air
- That could be
♪ Bloody mess in
my beard and hair
- Just hold on a
♪ Dead body on the kitchen floor
♪ What have I done?
♪ Me and my temper
♪ Blood on my sweatshirt
and blood on my hands
♪ Me and my temper
♪ Fucked up and I killed a man
♪ Drank too much Strongbow
♪ And things got
a tad out of hand
♪ Me and my temper
(sighs)
(screams)
- Come on mate, there's gotta
be a rational explanation
♪ Fast forward I'm on the run
♪ Drug mule classics
up my rectum
♪ Always on the move
to different places
♪ Killing my friends
on a daily basis
- Sorry
♪ Cocked up now nothings right
♪ Have to cook more
meth than Walter White
♪ Jump ship with Somali pirates
♪ Rob rich kids like Miley Cyrus
♪ Flee down to Mexico
♪ Where the people
will never know
♪ What I've done
'cos I'll never show
♪ Want to stay but I've gotta go
♪ Change my name to Luis
♪ So the people
don't take the piss
♪ Find a family and settle down
♪ 'Til some gang
from another town
♪ Come and brutally
murder the lot of 'em
- What are you talking about?
♪ Me and my temper
♪ Feel the devil inside of me
♪ Mum won't have
me round for tea
♪ Drunk too much Strongbow
♪ And things got
a tad out of hand
♪ Me and my temper
♪ When you get drunk
it's not what you do
♪ A pool he lies
♪ The food rage
takes a hold of you
♪ Since I've cried
♪ Only starch based
food will please ya
♪ That's when I saw you
heading for the freezer
♪ You're just a man
not a serial killer
♪ We're one short so
this lines a filler
♪ That's not blood
that you've got on ya
♪ That's microwavable
meat lasagne
♪ Sagne, sagne, sagne
(knife cuts packaging)
(microwave dings)
- That was it.
So what's up with him then?
- He's just sleeping.
Hey.
- Hey, think you're a cool guy?
- Who?
(rattling pans)
- What was that?
(whistling)
(strange groaning)
- What the fuck is that?
- Ah, it's fucking disgusting.
It's looking at me, I'm
gonna bash it's head in.
- Don't Dru.
- What is that thing?
- He's my son.
(sad music)
(creature chomps)
("Dru's Story (Me
and My Temper)")